Refugees are people who flee their country...
...to escape conflict or persecution.
But where do they go to find safety?
Most refugees can be found in countries...
...neighboring the country they have fled from.
Many want to stay close to family and friends...
...and hope to soon return home.
In many cases, it takes a long time until this is possible,...
...so they continue to live as refugees for many years.
The majority of refugees live in urban areas in their host country.
They rent in towns and cities and try to provide for their families.
Others live in refugee camps or improvised shelters...
...where living conditions can be at least equally challenging.
Some refugees have to stay in camps for years or even decades.
Today, most refugees can be found in Africa...
...and regions like the Middle East and South Asia.
Only a relatively small number can be found in industrialized regions...
...like North America, Europe and Australia.
The great majority of refugees, nearly nine out of ten...
...live in developing regions.
This means that some of poorest countries in the world...
...that already face economic and social challenges of their own...
...host huge refugee populations.